rebel Wilson is getting candid about  what it took to make it in Hollywood in  a new interview with The Telegraph the  Australian funny lady admits she gained  weight to get jobs whoa I thought how  can I get more laughs maybe if I was a  bit fatter and then suddenly I was  fatter and doing comedy but everyone is  hot rebel says losing out on a role to a  bigger actress kind of inspired her I  saw my size as being an advantage  whereas so many women see it as a  disadvantage rock it out still the  pitch-perfect star admits she has  thought about dropping the elby's but  says she has a hormonal imbalance that  makes her gain weight rapidly